ya platicamos mucho acerca de la
elasticidad de la demanda y de la
elasticidad cruzada de la demanda así
que es una buena pregunta es si existe
la elasticidad de la oferta que voy a
escribir aquí la elasticidad elasticidad
edad de la oferta
y la respuesta es que si también existe
la elasticidad de la oferta y tiene que
ver con cómo cambia porcentualmente la
cantidad ofertada según cambia
porcentualmente el precio entonces para
esto para hablar acerca de esto déjame
pintar una gráfica por acá tenemos el
eje de precio y acá tenemos el eje de
cantidad solo que ahora no va a ser una
curva de demanda sino una curva de
oferta de este lado tenemos precio acá
tenemos cantidad y las curvas de opel de
oferta se ven como así verdad se ven que
van hacia arriba más o menos algo de
este estilo entonces pensemos que
tenemos algunos puntos aquí no sé vamos
a hacer un poco más concretos digamos
que es un puesto de aguas frescas que
aquí tenemos una cierta cantidad de
precios por cada litro de agua fresca
que puede ser 10 pesos o 20 pesos y
estos 10 pesos hacen que se pidan no sé
digamos 10 litros y 10 litros de agua a
la semana
o al día y que estos 20 pesos hacen que
se pidan o bueno que se oferte en verdad
perdón esta es la de oferta entonces que
se ofrezcan 16 16 litros entonces 10
pesos se ofrecen 10 litros de agua 20
pesos se ofrecen 16 litros de agua al
día muy bien entonces ya tenemos nuestra
curva de oferta cómo le hacemos para
calcular la elasticidad de la oferta
pues la idea es muy similar ahora lo que
tenemos que poner lo voy a poner de este
lado lo que tenemos que poner es la
elasticidad de la oferta y para
calcularla tenemos que hacer un cambio
porcentual un cambio porcentual en la
cantidad otra veces en la cantidad pero
ojo ahora es en la cantidad ofertada
dividido entre el cambio porcentual
cambio porcentual del precio entonces es
exactamente la misma idea que la
elasticidad de la demanda sólo que ahora
es con la oferta entonces vamos a ver
cuánto nos daría en este ejemplo de acá
hasta acá arriba tenemos que poner el
cambio porcentual de la cantidad vas a
ver de aquí aquí digamos del punto a al
punto b aquí voy a poner
le voy a poner ven pues la cantidad
aumentó aumentó en 6 y que le pasó al
precio pues el precio pasó de ser 10 a
hacer 20 entonces el precio aumentó en
10 pesos van entonces aquí arriba
tendríamos que poner seis entre tenemos
que poner un cambio porcentual aquí
abajo debemos de poner el promedio de 10
y de 16 10 + 16 es 26 entre 12 es 13 13
y acá abajo tenemos que poner el cambio
porcentual en el precio el cambio fue de
10 y el promedio de 10 y 2015 acuérdate
que estamos haciendo cambios
porcentuales de la manera económica o
sea como se hace en economía vaya no nos
fijamos en los extremos como base para
hacer el porcentaje sino en el promedio
de las dos cantidades buenos algo ese
detallito en los que estoy acá vamos a
ver cuánto nos queda vamos a hacer las
cuentitas voy a sacar la calculadora
entonces la calculadora debe decir 6
entre 13 6 entre 13 eso de ahí es 46% y
luego 10 entre 15 10 entre 15
qué es 67 por ciento entonces es 43 y 67
16 43 verdad
146 y 67 entonces aquí es 46% y aquí
abajo es 67% así para encontrar la
elasticidad de la oferta hacemos esta
división 46 entre 67 dejar la
calculadora 46 entre 67 y nos queda que
la elasticidad de la oferta es de 0.68
y 0.68 muy bien entonces esta de acá es
la elasticidad de la oferta y así se
calcula vale entonces ahorita lo que
sería bueno es pensar en algunos
escenarios como en algunos casos
extremos para entenderla un poquito más
entonces bueno si no quedo positivo
porque si aumenta el precio aumenta la
cantidad vamos a ver si esto siempre
sucede vamos con algún caso extremo
digamos ahora vamos a pensar en un bien
y en elástico en el sentido de la oferta
voy a ponerle por acá el elástico
inelástico inelástico entonces pensemos
por ejemplo en mí o sea ya mí a mí me
gusta hacer vídeos lo disfruto mucho y
entonces realmente si si se modifica el
precio de los vídeos en el mercado yo
voy a hacer exactamente la misma
cantidad de vídeos entonces déjame poner
aquí los ejes ahí tenemos el precio ahí
tenemos la cantidad entonces como se
vería la curva de oferta de mis vídeos
pues digamos si si los vídeos cuestan
osea si me pagan cada vídeo no sea dos
mil pesos
estoy dispuesto a hacer tres a la semana
pero igual si me los pagan a 3000 o si
me los pagan a 10 pesos y ahí podría ser
10 pesos o sea no importa a qué precio
estén yo estoy dispuesto a hacer la
misma cantidad de vídeos también si me
los pagan a un millón ajá bueno ahí me
lo pensaría un poco pero no supongamos
que estoy dispuesto a hacer exactamente
la misma cantidad de vídeos y entonces
ahora la curva de oferta se vería más o
menos así y qué sucede cuando intentamos
calcular la elasticidad de la oferta
ahora tenemos que ver qué pasa con un
cambio porcentual en la cantidad
dividido entre un cambio porcentual en
el precio pero qué sucede sin importar
este cuánto cuánto cuesta cada vídeo yo
voy a hacer lo mismo entonces no importa
cuánto cambiamos el precio yo no voy a
cambiar mi cantidad ofertada entonces
aquí sería cero verdad dividido entre el
cambio porcentual del precio y en este
caso
pues la elasticidad de la oferta sería
igual a cero no importa cómo cambia el
precio yo voy a hacer exactamente la
misma cantidad de videos pero ahora
vámonos al otro extremo supongamos que
ahora tenemos un granjero ahora va a ser
un ejemplo de algo elástico en términos
de la oferta elástico entonces tenemos
un granjero que puede cosechar maíz o
puede cosechar trigo trigo bye
supongamos que le da igual cosechar maíz
o cosechar trigo entonces si al inicio
el maíz cuesta 10 pesos y el trigo
cuesta 10 pesos no sé a lo mejor el kilo
creo que creo que no soy muy bueno
calculando el precio de del maíz y del
trigo pero digamos que cuestan igual 10
pesos el kilo de maíz o de trigo y
digamos que la cantidad que produce el
granjero de cada uno es 200
a ese precio eso es lo que oferta
entonces qué sucede cuando cambia el
precio del maíz o como cuando cambian
bueno si vamos a enfocarnos en el maíz
pensando que el trigo queda constante
entonces qué sucede si el precio del
maíz baja y el precio de maíz baja
digamos si el precio baja a 9.99 pesos
el kilo pues como el granjero le da
exactamente lo mismo producir trigo que
maíz entonces ahora se va a dedicar a
producir trigo porque se lo puede vender
más caro vale entonces ahora si hacía
200 y 200 van a pasar a hacer lo voy a
poner con este color verde 0 y 400
entonces el maíz cambió drásticamente
con un ligero cambio en el precio y de
modo similar si el maíz cambia a 10
pesos cuando un centavo ahora todo se va
a concentrar en el maíz entonces cómo
quedaría la curva de oferta y la y la
elasticidad pues ahora la curva de
oferta se vería más o menos así
voy a poner aquí no sé digamos que hay
son kilos por decir algo entonces ahí
tenemos esto tenemos esta flechita esta
flechita de acá entonces muy bien
entonces aquí está 200 aquí tenemos
precio verdad este es precio esta es
cantidad entonces aquí está 10 entonces
cuando bajó tantito el precio y cuando
subió tantito el precio se movía
muchísimo la cantidad de maíz que se
producía o sea maíz que se ofertaba en
este caso que sucede pues la cantidad
aquí fue cero verdad en este puntito de
acá déjame ponerlo con otro color para
que se note mejor entonces la cantidad
fue cero cuando el precio fue en 9.99
luego la cantidad fue 200
y voy a poner que fue 200 y luego la
cantidad fue 400 cuando el precio subió
10 400 entonces tenemos este punto este
punto y este punto y en este caso la
línea o vaya a la curva de oferta se ve
casi como una línea horizontal que
sucede con la elasticidad de la demanda
o no perdón de la oferta en este caso
pues la elasticidad de la oferta ahora
como se calcula tenemos otra vez que
calcular el cambio porcentual de la
cantidad que en este cambio es algo muy
grande entre el cambio porcentual del
precio que es algo muy chiquito entonces
que nos quedaría para este ejemplo de
acá pues la elasticidad de la oferta es
un cambio porcentual de la cantidad
grande le voy a poner así grande entre
un cambio porcentual del precio chiquito
y entonces esto de acá pues es grande
verdad deja de ponerle que se van a
infinito entonces en este caso bueno acá
a la izquierda tenemos un ejemplo de un
bien y en elástico de hecho
perfectamente inelástico en términos de
oferta
aquí a la derecha tenemos que la
elasticidad se va a infinito y entonces
es un bien perfectamente elástico bueno
casi perfectamente las curvas pues voy a
poner aquí perfectamente elástico
plástico es que se va a infinito ya no
además como último detallito para para
pues hacer
las analogías con la elasticidad de la
demanda en la elasticidad de la oferta
también nos podemos preguntar por una
curva con elasticidad de la oferta
constante y yo digo que estoy aquí es
mucho más sencillo que en el caso de la
elasticidad de la demanda yo digo que
mira esta curva de acá que voy a pintar
que es súper sencillita
ya no sé ni qué pinta esta de acá que
súper sencillita tiene elasticidad de la
oferta unitaria y constante cuál es esta
curva pues simplemente la curva
identidad o sea la curva que tiene un
ángulo de 45 grados como le podemos ver
que tiene elasticidad de la oferta
constante pues básicamente nos fijamos
en un punto el que nosotros queramos
digamos este de acá y como tenemos
exactamente el mismo precio y cantidad
perdón precio aquí es precio y aquí es
cantidad entonces un cambio mira o sea
un cambio así un cambio en el precio
digamos de uno también nos da un cambio
en la cantidad de uno entonces
porcentualmente como también vale lo
mismo el precio y la cantidad
digamos cinco y cinco entonces el cambio
porcentual fue de aquí de 20% y aquí
también de 20% entonces en este caso y
justo porque las curvas de oferta tienen
pendiente positiva ahora van hacia
arriba es mucho más fácil encontrar una
curva con elasticidad de la oferta igual
a 1 elasticidad de la oferta igual a 1 o
sea una curva
una curva de oferta con elasticidad de
la oferta unitaria constante uff es un
trabalenguas súper complicado pero bueno
entonces esto de aquí son algunas ideas
de la elasticidad de la oferta nos vemos
hasta la próxima